[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [Applause]
mary wilson was one of the founding
members of the legendary supremes
and a friend of our show she was set to
join us as a guest co-host
to commemorate all the exciting things
she had in store this year
mary had so much to live for but sadly
instead of a celebration
we're mourning the loss of a music
pioneer
what made the supreme so special well
first of all we knew we were special
you know if we knew we were good we were
the first girl group there
at motown but we were the last ones to
get a hit record
that's how much we really believed in
ourselves
[Music]
mary's death came as a shock to many in
fact just this past saturday she filmed
this new video
for her youtube channel appearing
healthy and excited about her 77th
birthday next month
her upcoming new album and the 60th
anniversary of the supremes
they are going to release new recordings
mary wilson recorders yes at last
today celebrity action poured in her
longtime bandmate diana ross telling e.t
exclusively i remember mary's joy and
love during happier times
i'm happy to have known her
i do think the supremes showed the world
that
black women were gorgeous talented we
proved
the american dream we were the american
dream
dream girls was loosely based on the
supremes in 1977
they would go their separate ways and
mary continued her solo career
come on and save i walk down the street
now people say aren't you mary wilson
before it was you know they weren't sure
our last interview with mary was in 2019
when she competed on
dancing with the stars at the age of 75.
i'm still doing gigs oh my gosh
it shows all those people out there who
are in their 70s that you can still do
it
now i'm telling you i'm a little tired
you know what it feels like when your
dream really comes true
it's so real it stops you you have a
moment of silence
it's like whoa this is hey
oh excuse me
[Music]
you